throw to have back here on the Rich
Eisen show but for the first time as a
man who's been announced to be part of
Canton Ohio forever more Pro Football
Hall of Famer Bill Cowher here on the
show how does that sound bill I'm still
trying to get used to that one rich it's
been a short period of time but boy you
know it happened so fast what a
whirlwind we had two shows on the
weekend and you know now it's kind of
soaking in a little bit it's it's pretty
special yeah I know obviously being on
live television is sometimes difficult
enough even no matter how many times
you've done it because you're on live
television I mean what was going through
your head when David Baker appeared all
of a sudden you know I had absolutely no
idea in an ironic part of it was I sat
down that morning with my wife Veronica
or I call her gay all the time and she's
a musician and so um you know I talked
about I said I don't think I'm going to
get in and I'm okay with it
I almost put some closure on it and I
was okay you know and I came in no one
really said anything weren't disgusted I
thought well that's been pretty first of
all I appreciated them kind of like
given me my space from it all and I was
get ready to do an eye vision with with
phil simms and talking about lamar
jackson and next thing I turn around I
see David thinker we all know what he
stands for and and it just was a lot of
things to try to process at the time
it's kind of life it's not this isn't
this is the way I I thought this was
going to be I thought to get a call says
hey you know you're close but you think
an enemy we'd all find out on Tuesday
night or something because it's gonna
air on Wednesday and yeah it was almost
surreal and you know I asked you to duck
a speech wow that's definite time to
think about this one so it just kind of
rambles out and I got done I'm not sure
what I just said but it was a pretty
surreal moment and you know when you
have a time to sit back and reflect it
you realize just how special it is you
know when an elite group of coaches
particular
in the Hall of Fame that you're talking
about yeah it's a little overwhelming
rush to be quite honest with you now you
know I I'm still preparing for this
weekend's games we have one more show
you have a Super Bowl but you know just
you know every day you wake up it's just
like wow there's something you dreamed
about as a kid and you know you never
feel like your word you know look at all
the candidates that were there and it's
so funny i sat back and watched Jimmie
Johnson same thing happened to him about
half time with a part of the second game
on Sunday at all and I know exactly what
he was feeling about that I had to put
on a tweet night the first thing I
thought about is you know did Adam say
Lee really know that he had two future
Hall of Fame's players watching Bobby
Boucher in the water Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy
Johnson and I were down there and I
remember Jimmy and I think this is like
1997-98 what ever was and actually I
think it's like since then retweeted I
statement we're talking about boogaloos
Bobby Boucher and they said he sings
like Jack Taylor I don't know he's like
Greg Lloyd it goes whatever mom so it's
really really really kind of fun to
conquer be united with Jimmy about
little one that's fantastic bill I mean
that is just great and and uh you know
it's interesting to those may not know
because you're so synonymous with the
Steelers in that organization that your
NFL coaching career began in the state
of Ohio with the Browns as his special
teams and and defensive backs coach for
for the Marty Schottenheimer Browns back
in the day what if somebody came up to
that assistant and said it's all gonna
wind up in Ohio for you would that
assistant have said bill rich I you know
I went up there I quit playing more you
know if I want to come to be a special
teams coach I was already a special
teams cap but the Eagles in 84 of it I
was on IR you know and I was you know I
orthoscopic surgery don't you come back
I thought wow you know a chance getting
the coaching so I went there with Marty
and you know he I never coached before
in my life and Maury took a chance on me
for being a special teams coach I do it
for two years and say okay i won
the secondary go secondary on the
linebacker I don't know anything about
secondary play with because I guess you
have to find out just some research I
know ok um and I I did and then he went
to Kansas City and I followed him and
you know I've always said there's two
big mentors in my life
one of which is Marty Schottenheimer who
continued to give me more and more
responsibilities and allowed me to grow
as a coach and to grow as a person and
his work ethic is you know it's
unimaginable by what he does and he
could turn over every stone and and in a
day in Rudy you know 34 year old young
offensive coordinator for Kansas City to
come to Pittsburgh back to my hometown
to follow in the past you know Chuck
Noll and you know I always told the
story there really when I got the job
34 I'm going back to my hometown and I'm
thinking wow I just don't know if I can
not get far in the first three years I
can make my 20th high school class
reunion and so you know I I just didn't
want to screw it up the first three
years but you know so you go back there
you're with your parents um they're
seeing their grandkids I'm there for 15
years
Katey raised in the same house went to
the same school you know and I think the
first thing when things I think about
all the time if there's three people
that I know there was smiling on me from
above that's my mom and my dad and many
late wife Kay um you know she passed
away in 2010 and I met her in college
and and I stepped down quite honestly
because of her she was not in a good
place and passed away three years later
and you know assisting I've been
remarried but I've also been able to
experience another side of life has
given me more flexibility and gets more
balanced and so it's been a tremendous
nothing the tremendous rich and I have
been so blessed along a way to meet some
great people particularly in this
profession like yourself and beyond
working with him on Thursday Night
Football and you know and the CBS family
would that has been just so tremendous
to myself and give me a platform and I'm
a New Yorker through and through and and
you know it's just
an amazing path amazing journey and well
I'd like to think there's still a lot
more left Bill Cowher here on the Rich
Eisen show and we'll talk about the AFC
Championship game and we'll be on CBS
later on this weekend in just a second
and I'm I'm honored you it include me in
that in that list bill on because one of
my favorite memories of being a host for
NFL Network was in Detroit what turned
out to be you know your biggest night
professionally as a coach winning the
Super Bowl in Detroit and you come into
the set afterwards and then Bettis this
like 90 people coming to the set
afterwards after that that that big
night it was it's something I cherish
for sure that evening well you know what
you know that was a man you talk about
talking about a team on a on a mission
or that down is just texting with Mike
Vrabel and Mike I drafted Mike and you
know he could he placed me for four
years and I said man you're kind of
making every game personal here aren't
your car reminds me if I came back in
2005 and I like your demeanor right now
and so you know he you know and it
really was a special team you know we
went to Detroit and three road wins and
you know we had a chance to be the home
team I said nope we're in a row jerseys
because we're kind of road warriors and
I said well we love being the underdog
ago I think your favorite again I go no
or not don't don't let the facts get in
a way of a good in there so I said we're
underdogs I'm gonna make sure I feel
that way so it was um that was a special
that was a special special year be able
to hand and really that trophy that was
in my 14th year in the National Football
League yeah that meant a lot and last
one for you on the Hall of Fame stuff
you mentioned obviously Dan Rooney and
you mentioned Noel's name as well you're
gonna have a bust in the same room as
that bill I mean that's a fact and you
know that you guys right I mean and you
know that John Madden phrase that he
coined when he went into the Hall of
Fame about he believes that when the
lights go out the busts talk to
themselves I'm wondering I know it's
just I know it's first blush but
who would you want to have a
conversation with when the lights go up
when your bus goes in that room oh my
gosh it's a great great question I think
I the first person that comes to mind to
be quite honest with you is Vince
Lombardi I look at myself as a coach I
look at myself as someone that the way
he approached the sideline and you know
and I would love to have a much more
deeper talk with chuck you know I you
never shared a whole lot when I came in
for him and I almost feel like there was
the wisdom he passed on was you need to
do it your way you can figure out the
dough in yourself I would love to be
able to go back with Jack and have oh
can we just have some time to really
talk about this you know you know it's
just as a legendary franchise and I
think about those guys and then you look
up the guys like you know Dick Butkus
and you know and I guess Jack Lambert
like you buy her find and I love talking
to him I talked to Franco any chance I
can I grew up in Pittsburgh you can see
I was a Steelers fan growing up and
there's just so many guys I you know I
am just still overwhelmed I you know as
much as you watch it you see the people
in the back with her cold jackets on I'd
be honest with you it's I never
envisioned being up there I never did I
don't know I just I've been so much
respect for the game and feel like you
know I guess I was doing my job and my
job was not was to make sure you made
this people Pittsburgh proud and make
sure that the players handle themselves
in a professional manner and I want to
make sure I left that place in a better
place than when I got it I think that's
really the obligation we have with
anything we do in life to leave in a
better place than when you got it and
that if you can do that I think that's
one of the best contributions you can
make Bill Cowher here on the Rich Eisen
show and in terms of doing your job
sounds like you already are getting
ready for Sunday texting Vrabel here and
now this is this one is up I'm
particularly fired up about this bill
because certainly in this day and age
where so many rushing teams made the
playoffs this year and it seems that
there is some sort of watershed moment
interest
enough just a few months after last
season's game that went on tilt between
the Rams and the Chiefs it seems that
there's a lot more of a Smash Mouth
mentality we're gonna run it down your
throat and then hear the Chiefs
basically saying okay we're down to 24
guess what we'll just put a 50 burger on
you it does appear to be a clash of
styles I wonder what your first blush
analysis of this Sunday AFC championship
game is going to be well I mean yeah I
don't know if I've given the Titans even
a chance in either one of these first
two games but you know the one thing
they keep watching them do is is they're
not giving up big plays Ryan they're not
asking Ryan Tannehill to do anything
more than he's not he's uncomfortable
with you that he's not comfortable with
they're running the ball enough to make
the play-action work and Derrick Henry
is running like a beast I mean he is I
mean I've never seen a man run this
powerful this long and you know to the
course of a game if this thing stays
close you just have to wonder do they
just wear on you but there's one thing I
look at this football team as opposed to
the first two that they beat New England
we all know the struggles that they've
had offensively all year and so it was a
pretty good matchup for them I thought
last week in that game I thought
Baltimore showed a little bit of the
rust and they're really not a team built
to come from behind you know when you're
asked a limb are Josh Jackson to throw
the ball that many times hey you know
that's just not what he wants to do I
was surprised that the defense wasn't
able to stop Derek Henry and I think I
kept them close but boy when I see what
happened last week with the Kansas City
Chiefs you know that gives you a lot of
confidence Richmond you can sit there
and be done 2014 still come back the way
they did and say there's nothing that's
going to break you man I'm telling you I
I love Danny Reed's called me so what
will you think of when you're down 20
for nothing you know Tandy Reed said see
you score some points got to fix it and
move on yeah I love Andy Reed can you
it's hard not to pull for the man in
this 21st year we all know the
disappointments in a playoffs but you
know I just start to wonder
the stars on the white here it goes into
week 17 he's thinking playing next week
new English as well I got a bye Jerry
thinks okay we got to go to Baltimore
Baltimore loses oh they're coming to us
and now the Thunder coming to us and
here you are with a team that's a
contrast to you I know you won't look
ahead the boy it's hard not to pull for
him the guy who's been here for 21 years
and a great storyline with the Mike
bramble in a second year kind of imposed
themselves on the NFL and then in the
the other current topic I want to head
you on as well as the guy who succeeded
you in Pittsburgh who still has the job
because that's the way the Rooneys go
about their business I think bill and I
know this is saying a lot because they
were far from the Superbowl you could
make the case this was Tomlin's best
coaching job ever this past year what
did he say I said exactly the same thing
I said all year he did more with less
this year and I think he's a really good
coach I think you always took him for
granted because you always had all the
players and you say well boy with that
group of guys you should be winning 12
or 13 games but man you're coaching this
league and you you try to win as many
games as mike has won it's not easy I
don't care who you have and I think what
you saw this year was him being faced
with some adversity and the one thing
about that team is they fought every
week they followed him down that alley
even though the odds were against him
and I think that is a amazing testament
to him as a football coach he was able
to be resourceful he was able to take
the town when he had they want some an
offensive identity to a defensive
identity and trying to work with the
quarterbacks that he was working with
and Carey was in week 17 which still had
a chance to get the playoffs I totally
agree with you I think it was one of his
best coaching jobs yet last one for you
bill this is the way it's gonna be now
for the next several months and he's
about you know the the big enshrinement
for you and the bust the bust is gonna
be forever now your choice you have two
choices here you got the smiling Bill
Cowher when you win the Super Bowl that
Bill Cowher that's your bust or you got
the
y'all is straight out your your your
saying it and spraying it you're taking
the you're taking the the photograph the
Polaroid and you're jamming it right
into the shirt pocket or the official do
you want that Bill Cowher you want the
smiling Bill Cowher for your bust
what do you choice oh that's an easy one
I know I was on a sideline and if I'm in
there with the rest of my peers I need
to be the guy I was on the sideline not
the guy that I am now you know I just
call it the way it is if we're going to
be talking when the lights go down
they'll be talking some smiley face guy
they want to talk to the guy that they
know gonna bring it you're gonna bring
it with that bust essentially bill
congratulations I'm very thrilled for
you you know getting to know you again
throughout the years of interviewing you
when you were coaching and then
obviously hanging with you and Vee and
the rest of the CBS family on Thursday
nights when I got to do that very
thrilled for you and so by the way all
of Pittsburgh is as well bill all of
Pittsburgh is thanks I really appreciate
it you've been really appreciate
everything you're doing for the league
and what you guys represent over there
so trust me I'm I'm with you and I smile
with you today but know that bus should
not be smile take care of yourself
though thanks to the call got it that's
Bill Cowher he'll be part of the CBS
coverage of the AFC Championship game on
Sunday at Cour CBS on Twitter right here
on the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app